for most of the history of humanity
there was nothing at all one could
swallow when one was mentally ill
the full force of one's sickness had to
run unchecked
then in 1950 paul charpontier
a french chemist working at labratoire
ron poulonc
succeeded in synthesizing a drug called
4560rp
later renamed chlorpromazine when rats
were injected with it
placed in a crowded cage and convulsed
with electric shocks
they showed none of the expected alarm
and frenzy
settling instead into a serene and
indifferent mood
when given to humans the drug had a
similar calming effect
american soldiers in the korean war were
able to walk into the battlefield
with total fearlessness in hospitals
psychotic patients who were placed on
the drug became
sociable unaggressive and ready to
rejoin ordinary life
the world's first antipsychotic drug was
born
it would over the coming decades be
followed by dozens more seemingly
miraculous medicines
all of them playing in ways that their
creators did not and still do not
entirely understand
with the brain's receptors for dopamine
the hormone held to be responsible
for excessive excitement and fear
alongside these antipsychotics
there emerged a family of
antidepressants in particular those
known as
ssris that could increase the brain's
levels of serotonin
the neurotransmitter and hormone
associated with
uplift motivation and positive moods
the drugs were baptized with names that
put language to ever more daunting uses
fluoxetine citalopram paroxetine
esatalopram risperidone quetiapine
aripiprazole whatever the
particularities of each example
modern psychiatry ended up operating
with two essential instruments
pills that could calm us down reducing
terror
paranoia mania disinhibition insomnia
and aggression
and pills that could lift us up
alleviating despair
moroseness and loss of meaning
thanks to these medicines occupancy
rates of psychiatric hospitals plummeted
decreasing by some 80 percent in
developed countries
between 1955 and 1990
illnesses that had been a near death
sentence a generation before
could now be managed by swallowing one
or two pills a day
it looked as if our unruly minds had
finally been tamed
but the answer was not complete all
these medicines turned out to have
serious physical
side effects being intermittently
responsible
for dramatic weight gain diabetes kidney
malfunction
and blood clots yet the charge against
them at a psychological level
was more fundamental that they did not
and could never
on the basis of their approach get to
grips with the true causes of mental
illness
at best they could control appalling
symptoms
while being unable to grapple with what
in the individual
past had led to them in the first place
to be fair to psychiatry even if this
were true
it is no mean feat to be able to offer a
person a measure of control over their
mental symptoms
given the horrors that these can entail
those of us who have known mental
illness from close up
would at the height of our suffering
generally choose to be physically
tortured
rather than endure yet more of the
abominations our minds can inflict
there are varieties of mental unwellness
in which we are taken over by anxiety
and foreboding
and paralyzed by a sense that every
minute is carrying us closer to an
immense and unnamable catastrophe
we can no longer eat or speak we may
just have to lie in a ball
crying scratching ourselves and waiting
for the axe to fall
there are states in which we wake up
every morning with a conviction
that we need to take an overdose in
order to put an end to the turmoil in
our minds
there can be voices inside us that do
not for one moment cease
telling us that we are guilty shameful
and abhorrent beings
we may live in terror that we are about
to lose control
or might have already done so our
imaginations can be haunted by images of
stabbing a child
or tearing off our own fingernails it
can feel as if there is a monster inside
us
urging us to do appalling deeds and
filling our consciousness with
lacerating persecutory thoughts
we may feel our inner coherence
dissolving and giving way to a male
stream of aggression and paranoia
we may be so mysteriously sad that no
pleasantry or act of kindness can
distract us
and all we wish to do is stare mutely
out of the window
and hope to be gone soon
with the right pills in hand however
some of these nightmares can end
we may know our anxiety is still there
but we are granted some distance from it
we are able to stare at it as if it were
an enraged tiger in a zoo
on the other side of a thick pane of
glass
we may not lose sight of our despair and
self-loathing
but we can acquire an attitude of
detachment in relation to it
it doesn't matter quite so much that we
are entirely awful
and should be put down we can park the
idea for a morning in order to do some
work or clean the house
we can put off thoughts of suicide until
tomorrow
we don't need to have a complete
reckoning with our sadistic ideas
every moment the crushing sadness can
partially lift
and we might have the energy for a
conversation with a friend
or a casual walk in the park only
someone who hadn't endured vicious
mental suffering
would dare to casually dismiss such
psychiatric interventions
as a plaster over a wound nevertheless
most mental illness has a psychological
history
and its hold on us will for the most
part only properly weaken the more
episodes of this painful history we can
start to feel and make sense of
pills may be able to change the
background atmosphere of our minds
but our thoughts about ourselves need to
be challenged and adjusted
with conscious instruments if we are to
be able to grow truly well
the genuine resolution of mental
disturbance
lies in our ability to think especially
of our early childhoods
and the key figures and events within it
the unfortunate paradox is that
illnesses of the mind
generally affect precisely the
instrument that we require
in order to interpret our lives it is
our conscious reason that is both sick
and desperately needed in order to do
battle with despair and fear
it is the reason that we need in order
to locate persuasive grounds to keep
living
this is where pills may usefully join up
with psychotherapy
to deliver a coherent solution we might
say that the supreme role of pills
is to hold back panic and sadness just
long enough that we can start to
identify
why we might want to continue living
they aren't in themselves the cure
but they are at points the essential
tools that can make therapy
and through it authentic healing
possible
they promise our minds the rest and
safety they require
to harness their own strengths
our emotional first aid kit provides a
set of useful salves to some of life's
most
challenging psychological situations
including friendship